hey guys Ryan right here and belissa be
crazy this is a special episode today
where I'm gonna talk about something
awesome for all you gamer fans out there
yes I have recently become a subscriber
to something awesome
I saw a few youtubers get this thing
called a 1up box right here 1up box I've
been staring at this box for like an
hour yeah eating at me this is my first
[ __ ] box I'm so excited I'm so if you
do the math on what is in this box this
is like less than 13 bucks it's like
twelve dollars or some [ __ ] what you see
is in this box I'm like that one thing
alone is like 25 bucks like the shirts
they provide they provide a gaming shirt
on here yeah like every month and I'm
like that is awesome their shirts are so
expensive yes ok so Dan of that cyber
channel he was telling me about this
like months ago and I've been interested
in it ever since I've wanted to do it
for so long I walk in here and see that
nun like she's about to go down yeah so
this is my first one and I wanted to see
what's in this is apparently the
February edition like I first heard
about this because I saw zackscottgames
do this deadlock MCM X something like
that anyway so I saw them do it and I
was like I gotta get one of those
[ __ ] boxes like that that looks like
an amazing box so this is like The
Walking Dead themed box for February I
know we're already in March but I just
come I asked if I can still get a
February 1 we're gonna open this and see
what's in here
a 1up box reaction wait there's a thing
called unboxing videos yeah unboxing
videos are really really popular and
here's the thing when you watch more
YouTube I don't know how to open it
really I'm having a hard time yeah
I don't want that box to give away I
wanted to be like my perfect 1up box I'm
gonna get these it like every month I
wanted this to be my first one just open
the [ __ ] box you really have already
no just open now I want to see what's in
my box oh I get it all right Shh
everyone shut up
that means you atlas all right I'm gonna
put the box like this I'm just gonna
reach my hand in and not look I start
with something small it's like my new
sex all right something small zombie
antivirus what is it chaps
this is chapstick its it melts
directions wet hands thoroughly with
product and rub into skin until dry oh
cool zombie okay cuz it's Walking Dead
theme I was wondering like it's not a
spray teaching yeah that's actually it's
a keychain that'd be cool of 1up box
what's in it yes yes so Vaughn I'm
showing the people cherry sours this is
awesome like a Nintendo fan this is so
cool okay something small zombie strike
global al Break grenade what is it you
put this in your [ __ ] play with it I
don't know it just a stress ball or
sergeant
oh this is special oh really it's not
just a toy oh cool oh there's other way
Caesar hand and grip something to be
stress but whatever right
yes I have always wanted one of these
[ __ ] yes
it's Darrell no way is it really yeah oh
my god I've always wanted one of these
like I never was I'm not like a specific
one a Darrell but you know if I was
looking at Walking Dead stuff I would be
richer Darrell you know I always see
like the Batman ones and the Joker ones
too that's a little bit more valuable
yes it's a white doctor now I've got one
or two more items in here one more 1up
box February apocalypse pin would Kirby
on it oh and a zombie attacking curb you
know if you guys can see that I don't
want to deal with the focus right now
but anyway it's a pin and it looks
pretty [ __ ] sweet I'll put it on my
hat this is more incentive to wear my
hat more now
oh all right cool cool all right
last night I'm like it's the shirt I
don't know what the shirts of no it's
the shirt though how does all of this
stuff it now pop it's the Box it's the
Box goddess no way
no dude and this feels cuff I'm so done
and where the scene shirts all
and like it's because I vote for shirts
that feel comfortable on my every body
and everybody's like one of the shirts
that will fit on my hairy body oh my god
oh my god oh my god it's really gonna
have sex in this shirt keep the shirt on
damn zombie Kirby super was to cross
brothers super cross brothers yeah I am
so jealous right now like there isn't
enough peanut butter in the world to go
on my jelly sandwich oh it feels nice
too is that keema I don't know I think
it's silk oh they got heart is this what
is this heart-shaped heart other Zelda
heart oh cool I hate you so much right
now my good anyway um yeah I put a link
in the description box you could go to
that link if you want to join but yeah I
know like every month it's a different
theme seriously this [ __ ] alone is like
I'm sure you think all this would be oh
god I don't know well over $12 yeah yeah
anyway uh yeah just wanted to share with
you guys
water to rub it in your face of what I
own now no I wanted to say thank you
guys thank you because I can get [ __ ]
like this now because of you guys
seriously Wow like a lot of people don't
know this but I was actually able to
replace my job with YouTube and because
of you guys that is the only reason why
and now you I wanted to share the kind
of toys I get with the money you've
helped me earn you guys this is like the
coolest thing ever
yeah I don't want to give back I want to
give more to me I want to get these so
bad I just found out this shirt is sold
exclusively through
1up box I can't even go online and get
it now and iced you guys always ask me
about my shirts of where I got them I go
to special places this is one of the
exclusive membership places where I
could get this new shirt every month
it's a different theme of like game [ __ ]
so yeah it's [ __ ] awesome so it's
important Lee tell you what you're doing
right now jiggly jelly inside jokes
anyway guys if you're new the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and alissa be crazy has a channel too
there's a lot of fun [ __ ] on there you
should check that out it's growing
really fast right now if I go there to
see why it's good yeah and you could use
your hand and grip something hard
well yeah watch Alyssa be crazies
channel you know what I mean
eighty-four percent of the demographic
on the real rejects is male I'm
promoting you properly thank you I have
respect for women and I want them to
show you the best kind of respect one of
my best friends everybody